started your christmas shopping yet well
this could help if not registered
dietitian Abby sharp has some great tips
to keep you happy and healthy during a
power shop and we're talking during the
commercial break I really had for this I
get hangry we are very hungry and I get
in a bad mood oh yes so the first thing
you got to think about if you want to
avoid the hangry you've got to start the
day with a good healthy breakfast ok
that means protein oh yeah so I like to
do a combo of protein fiber and some
healthy fats ok that's really gonna keep
you full that's here then exactly we got
some Greek yogurt some berries some
almonds on top hold that so delicious
there you go really satisfying gets you
through to lunch ok so a good little mix
there yep exactly tip 2 you really want
to think about packing some emergency
snacks because we just talked about
getting angry yes we wanted us cry
that's why I hate like power marathons
oh yeah because it's like I can't handle
it exactly so if you're getting in line
and you know you're gonna be in line for
a long time I like to have some
emergency snacks something that doesn't
need to be refrigerated fresh fruit so
you can just have it in your bed exactly
some little almonds I have a sweet tooth
I don't know about you should I like to
put a little little individual wrapped
pieces of dark chocolate ok cuz that way
when you walk by the mall and you smell
like those cinnamon buns yes that gets
you you can crush that sugar craving
minimal damage ok and that's chocolate
that's good thank you so don't put a
whole chocolate models walk up are these
are like little individually brown piece
ok all right next choose quality
ingredients that's super important
because i like to eat locally as pot as
soon as possible because local food it
tastes better it's better for you you
get so much more out of it when i eat
low great but if you're at the mall and
you're at the food court what are your
choices well you know five years ago
would have been absolutely impossible
but now more and more chains are really
catching on ok and one of my favorites
is rich tree natural markets and they
have recently announced all their meat
is preservative-free hormone-free
antibiotic-free and they're sourcing
locally whenever possible ok so to me
that's a huge step forward in the right
direction when it comes to eating
healthy at the know they it in food
court said yeah they are ok so that's
really really great next little tips
speaking of meats when you're choosing
your fillings for your sandwiches if you
want to go for a sandwich at the mall
avoid the chicken salad the egg salad
tuna salad right they sound healthy
simply I kind of salad well II sandwich
right zactly yeah cuz it's got me up
exactly so all that mail hundred
calories per tablespoon in mayo and they
are not going easy on that so okay right
so I always say go for a really like
simply prepared sandwich with no sauce
added and then you can do some mustard
on the side or but the most wrong
because it's virtually calorie free
right because you do need like something
good and and that's something that's
going to fill you up designs on it
yourself it's all about feeling
satisfied okay so last quick little tip
here super important customized to
optimize your meals nutrition this is so
simple because a lot of restaurants now
they'll happily substitute your fries
for like side salad little extra veggies
no problem one of my favorite little
tricks for customization is to turn my
you know rap or my burrito or my
sandwich into a salad and also easily do
this okay so just don't have them wrap
it up exactly so load up on the bed you
say more veggies lean meat so you can
get rid of the carbs from the rap or the
bread if there's any rice in there you
can get rid of that as well save serious
calories ask for the sauce on the side
and you know rich tree does a really
great job at the customization as well
so okay that's fantastic and if anyone's
in mississauga rich tree is now actually
opening relaunching on monday november
24th there relaunching in square one
okay so now there's plenty of good
healthy options when you're up okay also
a good idea to carry water with you
right oh my goodness hundred percent we
don't want anyone shop until they draw
thing literally yeah because yeah
because sometimes you're not necessarily
hungry you're probably thirsty because
the malls are dry they are very dry and
then you don't want to get stuck again
in that line up feeling like you know
you're parched and that often leads to a
little bit of a bad right what about to
if you're going anything oh you know I
need that energy jolt I need I need a
big coffee kind of thing because
sometimes the coffee drinks can be Oh
Hunter's loaded with sugar and fat so
you know if you need a coffee to get you
through the day I say go for a small one
try to fuel yourself with healthy food
and that's really where we start the day
with a nice healthy breakfast if you
start the day with a good healthy
breakfast with some fiber and some
protein and some of those good for you
healthy fats you're not going to be
feeling that dip and needing to chunk a
bunch of that sugary coffee
okay some good tips there maybe even
help you stay happy if you're not
finding parking spots before hands right
that's a whole that's a whole other
thing okay Abby thanks so much and we've
got tub more news coming up right keeps
you healthy food